[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des pâtés aux formes différente
richement décoré et parfois fleuri pour
cette 5e édition du concours 17
réalisations espèrent décrocher le titre
final celui du meilleur pâté de Houdan
cette spécialité evvelinoise est la
fierté ancestrale de la ville et de sa
confrériie qui défend son histoire et
les règles de sa fabrication vous avez
une pâte à pâé hein d'accord et puis
ensuite vous utilisez la la volaille de
de Houdan hein c'est qu' un pompon qui
qui est une volaille qui est qui est
noire avec des avec des points blancs
euh dessus euh donc ça c'est la
particularité une vous mettez pas il y a
pas de foirat dedans il y a pas de truve
dedans hein il y a pas ces produits qui
sont des produits luxes après c'est
d'aller chercher avec la volaille
l'équilibre avec le gras euh d'utiliser
les foie aussi hein qui amène aussi un
goût très particulier assez fort euh
mais qu'il faut essayer de maîtriser
avec le sel le poivre c'est ça la
particularité du pâté de woudan des
particularités qui sont notées selon des
critères précis le pâté est d'abord jugé
sur l'aspect visuel les pièces sont
présentées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entièrees avant d'être découpé en tranch
et là encore rien de s'improvise une
croûte ça se coupe avec un couteauuss
mais les pâés en croûte généralement il
y a un apport d'humidité on peut pas
donc il faut un couteau extrêmement fin
rigide les tranches sont observées
minutieusement par trois jures qui
départagent les pièces dans les trois
catégories du concours professionnel
apprentis et particulier malgré la
différence de niveau entre les
participants le cru 2023 semble de bonne
qualité il y en a des très très beaux
avec des beaux dessins un peu moins
c'est vraiment une belle prestation
cette année par rapport au années
précédentes il vent des beau puis vient
la dernière partie du concours ce que
vous attendiez tous la dégustation et la
cuisson de la croûte ainsi que la
dégustation de l'ensemble de votre pâté
donc tout ce qui va être les saveurs en
bouche et ceter les saveurs sont
harmonieuse y a-t-il de la finesse dans
le goût des différents ingrédients la
croûte est-elle suffisamment craquante
et sa cuisson homogène c'est sur tous
ces aspects que les jurés sont attentifs
et c'est là que les pâté se départagent
vous avez deux produits dont un qui
arrive franchement tête et qui donne
envie de de de d'être d'ê dégusté sur
les produits il y a une certaine
maîtrise de
fabrication et ça se ressent parce que
je dirais que le produit en
sélectionnant les ces deux parties de la
pâte et de la farce mais ça fait un
produit homogène et tout à fait tout à
fait honorable donc c'est c'est de ce
côté-là on ressent tout de suite le
professionnel qui a passé du temps à
préparer à mettre au point son produit
une fois les vainqueurs par catégorie
départagés quatre jurés se réunissent
une dernière fois pour désigner le Grand
Prix
d'Honneur 3 jours plus tard le suspense
est levé les résultats du concours sont
révélés au restaurant la
poularde Vian et Lecoq enseignant
formateur à l'école Ferrandi se classe
premier dans la catégorie
professionnelle et remporte le Grand
Prix d'Honneur du concours du meilleur
pâté de Houdan son pâé est celui qui
représentait la lettre H dans la farce
c'est pour
moi une belle récompense d'un travail
qu'on a qu'on a mené depuis quelques
mois on a fait pas mal d'essais des
choses positives des choses un peu moins
et voilà derrière on a travaillé sur sur
cette présentation un petit peu original
pour mettre en avant la volaille de
Houdan c'était un pâté qui
était
manifestement mieux présenté mieux
cuisiné et cuit et il y avait des
caractéristiques intéressant dans la
catégorie apprenti c'est Gaspar niquez
en formation à l'école Ferrandi qui
s'impose j'ai appris que que j'étais
sélectionné pour le concours il y a un
peu moins de de mois de cela les
entraînements ont ét très difficiles et
ben ma réaction à ma victoire était
d'abord un soulagement et puis euh et
puis une grande fierté après le lauréa
dans la catégorie particulier est
Alexandre tis habitant de Versailles en
tout cas les 17 participants ont tous
gagné sur un aspect ils permettent de
faire perdurer cette longue tradition du
pâté de Houdan